Je déteste pas l'école mais je suis quand même bien content de plus devoir y retourner
Cyprien, t'es en danger de mort,
tu as 2 solutions pour rester en vie,
soit je t'envoie dans la passé
grâce à cette télécommande,
Non, non non, ça non !
Soit je te fais écouter un petit morceau
que j'ai composé, super sympa.
Non, non non,
je vais prendre le premier truc, en premier.
Tant pis pour toi,
c'était un super morceau.
Téléportation...
Ca fait plusieurs années que l'école c'est terminé pour moi
Pourtant, je peux pas oublier
plein de petits trucs que je déteste à l'école,
des trucs mais tout cons
mais qui m'énervent...
La mine de mon crayon
qui reste au fond du taille-crayon...
Quand je fais baver un trait tracé
en enlevant la règle...
Coller avec la colle UHU
alors que y'en a plus...
Alors je suis obligé de gratter le petit truc
en plastique au fond pour récupérer de la colle...
Bon, quand tu fais ça souvent ça veut dire :
achète une nouvelle colle !
Froisser sa feuille en gommant...
Mettre ma main sous la table
et toucher un chewing-gum..
Oooooohh !!
Mon voisin qui fait tout pour pas être copié...
Me tromper de salle..
Désolé pour le...
Au revoir !
Mordiller le stylo de quelqu'un d'autre..
Tu mordilles mon stylo là.
Oh pouaaah...
Renverser mon taille crayon
dans la trousse...
Me piquer avec la pointe du compas
en mettant ma main dans la trousse..
Ah putain !
(Le compas)
AHAHAHAHAh !!!
Quand le prof efface le tableau
mais laisse un bout..
A ce moment là,
j'ai tellement envie de prendre la brosse
pour effacer le petit bout là, de merde,
pour que le tableau soit nickel,
c'est rien, c'est simple pourtant
mais je ne le fais pas sinon
on va ma prendre pour un fou et
je serai humilié le reste de l'année scolaire.
Regarder ma montre deux fois
dans la même minute..
(Putain !)
Me mettre du stylo sur les doigts
en mettant le capuchon..
Alors, du coup, j'efface avec l'effaceur
mais j'ai les doigts qui puent après.
Quand le prof veut interroger quelqu'un..
Bon, qui passe au tableau ?
Alors là, la technique,
c'est d'éviter tout contact visuel avec le professeur.
Cyprien !
Putain..
Mais ce qui m"énerve le plus, à l'école,
quand le prof est pas là..
Bon, ça fait 15 minutes...
on y va ?
(Tous)
Ouais, ouais...
Désolé pour le retard,
sortez votre livre page 43.
(Fais chier !)
Tout est pas tout noir à l'école,
loin de là..
Y'a même parfois des petits moments de joie,
c'est pas souvent mais
ça fait kiffer.
(le proviseur)
le professeur est absent.
YES !
(le proviseur)
On va regarder un film aujourd’hui.
YES !
(le proviseur)
Il y a une manifestation.
YES !
(le proviseur)
On manifeste pour quoi déjà ?
On s'en fout !
Mon pire ennemi à l'école,
je m'en rappelle comme si c'était hier...
Quand je me faisais chier en cours,
je pouvais faire n'importe quoi,
de tout façon, n'importe quoi était
toujours plus intéressant que le cours en face...
La liste non exhaustive que
je faisais quand je m'ennuyais en cours :
Le jeu des barres pour faire des carrés.
Pincer mon doigt dans les anneaux des classeurs
pour voir si ça fait mal...
Et du coup,
ca fait un peu mal mais ça va.
Maintenant, je sais.
Pour les filles,
écrire SOLEIL avec sa calculatrice.
Pour les mecs,
écrire ELLE BAISE avec sa calculatrice.
Enlever les bouts de feuilles
dans les spirales des cahiers.
Dans la catégorie dessin :
le lapin derrière le mur,
le S avec les carreaux,
la rosace avec le compas
et remplir un carreau sur deux.
Collectionner les billes de cartouche d'encre...
Ca sert à rien, j'avoue.
Mais si jamais y a besoin,
j'en ai...
Construire une sarbacane
avec un effaceur.
Faire des trous dans une gomme.
J'en faisais plein..
je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Faire rebondir mon stylo.
C'était nul,
mais je le faisais quand même.
Jouer avec la barre du capuchon de mon stylo
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit tordue.
Écouter de la musique
avec un écouteur dans la manche...
Ouais , ça va loin.
Construire un missile avec une cartouche vide,
du papier et de la colle...
Direction plafond.
Bien sûr quand je m'ennuyais
je discutais avec mon voisin,
mais attention, fallait pas que
je me fasse griller par le professeur et là,
j'ai développé des aptitudes exceptionnelles.
J'étais le meilleur au monde au 1,2,3 soleil.
Très juste, vous pouvez continuer monsieur
s'il vous plait.
Mais attention,
je travaillais quand même a l'école.
Un peu..
Un tout petit peu..
Un petit petit peu..
Et toi,
t'en penses quoi de l'école ?
Lache un com, mets-toi bien,
fais comme chez toi !
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle . Correction : Les Masquet